novembre 2014 c'est la fin des audiences
publiques de la commission d' enquête
sur l'industrie de la construction
pour l'occasion la présidente france
charbonneau prenons ce discours
ses premiers mots sont destinés aux
commissaires renaud lachance pour sa
grande collégialité sens profond sens de
la justice
sa rigueur intellectuelle
sa droiture d'esprit sa grande capacité
d analyse ses connaissances approfondies
en plusieurs domaines et son dévouement
du fond du coeur et au nom de toute la
commission
merci monsieur lachance un an plus tard
la commission dépose son rapport
pour l'occasion la présidente prononce
le discours cette fois les remerciements
sont pour la fin je remercie le
commissaire ma chance d'avoir accepté de
relever ce défi avec moi sa connaissance
de l'appareil gouvernemental a été réel
atout pour la commission le ton est
moins élogieux le conflit qui couvait
depuis plusieurs mois entre les deux
éclater au grand jour
renaud lachance se dissocie du chapitre
sur le financement des partis politiques
provinciaux des élus ou d'ex élus
libéraux 113 de le souligner amir
mayenne pris dans l'eau les deux comme
fer était pas d'accord toutes les
opinions et neil d'enchaîner pour le
commissaire renaud lachance a inscrit sa
dissidence aujourd'hui c'est fondamental
le cogneur la chance d'y des pressions
faites dans la capitale entre le
financement des partis politiques et
l'octroi des contrats enquête a obtenu
des documents internes de la commission
il nous éclaire sur les motivations
d'une commissaire et soulève des
questions sur celle de l'autre
le 19 octobre 2011
jean charest annonce qu'il crée une
commission pour enquêter sur l'industrie
de la construction
la commission a pour mandat de mettre en
lumière les stratagèmes en les
identifiant en les exposant en formulant
des recommandations pour l'avenir
c'est la juge france charbonneau de la
cour supérieure qui va présider la
commission ancien procureur de la
couronne c'est elle qui a fait condamner
maurice boucher à la prison en 2002 et
elle a plus de 80 procès criminel à son
actif
c'est elle qui choisit les deux autres
commissaires roderick mcdonough
professeur de droit à l'université
mcgill et renaud lachance comptable
professeur à l'école des hautes études
commerciales au moment où france
charbonneau le recrutent et les
vérificateur général du québec depuis
je vous demanderais maintenant de bien
vouloir vous lever pour observer
quelques instants de recueillement wade
rich media annonce tombe malade et
décède avant la fin du processus
ils ne sont plus que deux pour diriger
la commission pour trancher les
questions difficiles
isabel richer était aux premières loges
de la commission charbonneau leur
relation et terre manieuse du départ et
il se complétaient bien les deux comme
sert autant dans leur personnalité que
dans leur façon de poser des questions
vous savez que ça se faisait oui et vous
savez que c'est illégal
je savais que c'était la police était
illégale je savais que des prête-noms le
dépôt n'était pas permis au pays
d'éviter illégale au sens aloi
puis arrivé avec la question ou avec le
commentaire qui faisons en sorte que ç'a
débloqué et toute la salle mais
réagissaient enfin renaud lachance
viennent poser une question comment un
ancien ministre
à côté de vous on peut oser geste
illégal et vous laisser faire vous avez
trompés si oui les journalistes
catherine kovacs et eric plouffe ont
aussi couvert toutes les audiences de la
commission renom la chance lui avait su
prédire le diable de faim de témoignages
il ya eu certes un échange musclé ou un
moment donné justement la fin de la
journée il a sorti son apport cote
c'était comme on était tous très étonné
où on s'excuse pas de l'avoir fait non
le fait l'opinion de participer dans des
scènes à grenade les excuses mais je
crois que vous devriez vous excuser de
l'avoir fait
nous sommes au printemps au moment de la
rédaction du rapport
les commissaires à note les textes et
font des choix
c'est dans ce contexte qu'a la fin de
l'été france charbonneau est criard nous
la chance et mais plusieurs personnes
on copie conforme cher nous je te fait
parvenir une autre copie du texte
encore une fois rhmani j'ai essayé de
voir ce qu'ils te déplaît la tension est
évidente il y aura bientôt un mois que
tu as décidé de l'ignorer
pourtant je te rappelle que notre devoir
va au delà nos différents
ses intentions sont claires elle veut
rallier renaud lachance qui menace de se
dissocier du chapitre sur le financement
des partis politiques
il me fera grand plaisir de changer le
texte
c'est pourquoi j'aimerais que tu
m'indique preuves à l'appui ce pourquoi
tu n'es pas d'accord
quelques jours plus tard france
charbonneau reçoit sète télécopie de
renaud lachance
envoyé à plusieurs membres de la
commission
c'est ce document que nous avons obtenu
une version préliminaire du chapitre sur
le financement des partis politiques
avec ses commentaires il y en a environ
80 comme france charbonneau sans doute
nous espérons comprendre pourquoi ce
professeur d'université ancien
vérificateur général crois qu'il n'y a
pas de liens entre l'octroi de contrats
et le financement politique
voici quelques exemples de ces
commentaires
il ya des élections générales au québec
que le 26 mars prochain
la ministre line beauchamp qui est
organisatrice la campagne pour le plq se
rentrent déjeuner au club 350 sciatique
et un job select et à ce petit déjeuner
on retrouve plusieurs ingénieurs de
firmes influentes de montréal plusieurs
entrepreneurs
on a su par la suite que c'était des
collusions honneur au niveau de la ville
de montréal bernard trépanier monsieur
3% celui collectait pour le parti de
gérald tremblay donc tous ces gens là se
retrouvent un déjeuner en la présence de
la ministre beauchamp qui est pas
accompagnée par son personnel politique
alors madame beauchamp à l'époque s'est
expliqué en disant que oui elle était là
pour tâter le pouls de la métropole des
besoins est ce qu'on sait c'est que
c'était le matin d'une grande activité
de financement pour le plq donc tous les
gens qui étaient là au petit déjeuner
allait se retrouver le soir pour la plus
part à cette grande activité de
financement est ce que vous allez
conduire avec moi que ces deux métaux
minés ces risques sont ce que ça se fait
en corse aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui non je n'étais que ce soit
fait dans un cadre plus formel la
version préliminaire du chapitre parle
de rencontres qu'on peut qualifier d'
inappropriée en raison du fait qu'elles
étaient réservés à quelques personnes
est tenu dans un cadre confidentiel et
privés renaud lachance ray cette phrase
est écrit ridicule il ne faut avoir rien
vécu dans sa vie pour écrire ceci
le mou ridicule sera répété à cinq
reprises dans les commentaires de renaud
lachance souvent sans plus
d'explications
plusieurs passages du document concerne
l'ex ministre nathalie normandeau son
chef de cabinet bruno leur tee et l'ex
ministre libéral marc yvan côté marc
yvan côté et bruno lortie sont très
proches ils ont tous les deux confirmé à
la commission charbonneau et ce lien là
entre les deux c'est pas anodin parce
que à l'époque marc yvan côté était vice
président d'une firme de génie la firme
roche et en plus à eux deux ils
faisaient du financement politique pour
le compte de nathalie normandeau et ces
deux là marc yvan côté et bruno lortie
ont été éclaboussés par une autre
commission la commission d'amm
quel est le montant total que vous avez
reçue en argent comptant coupure s'en
remet à la commission gomery marque man
côté a admis avoir distribué pour cent
vingt mille dollars d'argent comptant à
des organisations libéral pour financer
notamment des organisateurs politiques
et qui se trouvait parmi eux son grand
ami bruno lortie je me suis dit je peux
pas croire avec ce qu'ils ont vécu adam
reed qui voir comment cela va
recommencer
et moi j'étais convaincu me semble que
quand tu brûles les douanes fois tu
recommences pas l'année d'après on a
demandé à violette trépanier qui
s'occupait du financement et du
recrutement au plq
quel genre de vérifications elles
avaient pu mener pour s'assurer que
bruno lortie faisaient du financement
politique dans les règles de l'art j'ai
demandé à monsieur lortie est-ce que
tout est conforme et lui me dit oui tout
est conforme
renaud lachance encadre la phrase
considérant que l'ordi a été cité lui
aussi dans le rapport gomery en rapport
avec les agissements de marc yvan côté
cette mesure de vérification plus que
sommaire laisse évidemment songeur
il écrit dans la marge propos nécessaire
pourquoi taper sur quelqu'un qui est
déjà à terre on ne sait pas pourquoi
renaud lachance estimait que bruno
lortie était déjà à terre ce n'est pas
l'impression qu'il a laissé à plusieurs
témoins de la commission le sujet sur
lequel renaud lachance enrayer le plus
de passage c'est sur la ministre
nathalie normandeau et sa gestion du
programme de subventions pour les usines
de traitement des eaux contexte nathalie
normandeau elle a un pouvoir
discrétionnaire
elle fournit ou approuvent des
subventions pour des projets d' usine de
traitement des eaux et dans certains cas
elle peut majorer ses subventions et
elle s'en est pas privé et c'est des
données qui sont assez éloquentes là qui
parle d'elle-même
alors donc c'est un tableau
effectivement qui met en valeur le fait
que roche rachat est allé chercher un
bon nombre de dossiers à part au zoo
nathalie normandeau nient avoir fait du
favoritisme mais la firme quand même
qu'elle favorisait malgré tout sa région
elle était de la gaspésie nie aussi
avoir favorisé roche
sauf que lorsque vous regardez les
chiffres roche est allé chercher le
pactole
renaud lachance voulait couper trois
pages qui critiquait la gestion du
programme et les explications de
nathalie normandeau il écrit propos ne
concernent pas le mandat de la
commission n'est pas de la collusion
n'est pas de la corruption n'est pas du
financement des partis politiques
tout ceci ressemble à une forme de
procès le document proposait une
conclusion claire le pouvoir
discrétionnaire qui étaient à la
disposition de la ministre en faciliter
les échanges de faveur entre son cabinet
est une firme de génie privé
renaud lachance raid un grand trait de
plume et écrit aucune preuve pour dire
ceci
michel samson celui qui a succédé à
renaud lachance au poste de vérificateur
général du québec avait critiqué la
gestion de ce programme sous le règne de
nathalie normandeau le document le site
à quelques reprises sans explication il
raye tous les extraits du rapport de
michel samson
et
on nous dernier quand elle écrit son
courriel à renaud lachance france
charbonneau crête déjà les conséquences
s'il ne réussit pas à rallier son
collègue si tu décides d'inscrire tes
commentaires dans le mou du commissaire
plutôt que dans le texte
tu sais que cela va détourner
l'attention des médias et la population
et va faire porter le débat sur nous
plutôt que sur le rapport
est ce bien cela tu veux que vous les
renaud lachance
nous analysons 80 commentaires relevant
qu'il a identifié des erreurs proposer
des changements de justesse mais les
deux tiers de ces commentaires atténue
la responsabilité des acteurs politiques
adoucissent la critique envers les
partis politiques et en particulier le
parti libéral qui a été beaucoup plus au
coeur du mandat de la commission
voici nos deux derniers exemples on a
entendu un autre club bien intéressant
la commission charbonneau ont toujours
lié au financement à politique des
partis c'est l'histoire la piscine
municipale de saint sauveur qui était
racontée par un ces mères ont passé
qu'on serait capable de se payer une
piscine si on obtenir une subvention
équivalant à au moins 50% du coût de
l'infrastructure
l'ex maire de saint flour vers un michel
lagacé va faire une demande de
subvention d'un programme qui relève
d'une star de michelle courchesne
mais après trois ans de démarches
meilleur rien que boucher j'ai téléphoné
à l'attaché politique de madame
courchesne dahmane la ministre de
l'éducation du loisir et du sport
et puis mes faire comme réponse si le
ministre régional jean paul ii ou qe on
regarde même pas le dos si ce ministre
régional basse et le ministre
responsable de la région des laurentides
davet de ouessant le maire lagacé baba
se tourner vers son attaché politique à
médis
c'est qu'ils s'occupent du dossier
monsieur lagacé mais je sais moi ce
match comme si douce et la danse pas
demain que ça marche a toujours présenté
quelqu'un ce quelqu'un c'est christian
côté qu'on a entendu devant la
commission charbonneau
c'est un urbaniste à l'emploi de dessau
donc christian courte et c'est un
collecteur de fonds pour le plq un grand
ami du ministre whissell le main lagacé
va rencontrer ce monsieur côté mais au
bout de trois rencontres il va demander
des clarifications
ce côté je dis que c'est que vous devez
vous les inquiétudes précoce et d'agacer
steak ou si c'est pas votre film qui
obtiennent contrôle d'israël sur ça
s'arrange
je peux vous aider à passer ce moment où
il me dit ça s'arrange du ca ca y est
ils appliquent pas question que ça sera
chez nous finalement des sceaux arrive
deuxième n'a pas le contrat puis le
projet ben fini sur une tablette au
sujet de la saga de la piscine les
bouches de chapitres concluait que ce
récit témoigne d'une intervention
politique manifeste dans la sélection
des dossiers éligibles à l'octroi de la
subvention mais renaud lachance est
sceptique il raye est écrit il s'agit
d'un programme avec un pouvoir
discrétionnaire accordée au ministre il
est normal qu'ils interviennent ainsi
que le ministre régional et le conseil
des ministres
le dernier exemple concerne les plus
hautes autorités du parti libéral à la
commission charbonneau il a été
abondamment question d'un personnage
marc bibeau qui était un proche de jean
charest qui était le grand argentier du
parti libéral du québec est parmi ceux
qui en ont parlé
l'ancien député libéral de rush robert
benoit moi je vais prendre 10 12 14
repas par semaine avec mes confrères et
mes concerts et là ils s'échangent pas
mal d'informations beaucoup
d'informations et là il ya un nom qui
commence à circuler qui m'énerve qui me
fatigue et c'est le nom de marc bibeau
il la rencontre taille a mis de la
pression dans un passage au sujet de
marc bibeau renaud lachance rei la
phrase bibeau n'était pas seulement le
responsable du financement plq en marge
du texte il écrit important seuls robert
benoit a dit qu'il a entendu dire que
bebo était le responsable du financement
en fait bibeau n'a jamais eu de
fonctions officielles au plq
et pourtant plusieurs témoins dont des
gens du parti libéral l'ont dit devant
lui sabine azema qui commence a été à
plusieurs reprises qui est un monsieur
marc bibeau qui était la personne
responsable du financement partie
il y avait ma maman violette trépanier
puis monsieur marc bibeau que j'ai
rencontrés avec avec habituellement
d'être monsieur marc bibeau et des fois
avec la direction générale
certains députés et d'autres fois tous
les tous les députés pour leur parler de
leur de leurs objectifs de finances va
voir comment ils allaient l'attaquer
j'étais au courant bien formés et marib
au financement
sectorielle deux parties devraient
expliquer moi quelle est la
responsabilité de monsieur bibeau selon
vous le rapport aux finances mois-ci
legault qui s'occupe des finances du
parti je pense qu'il y avait comme une
petite carte d'affaires je te marquer
conseiller du premier ministre shlomo
drapeau du québec ça valait d'une carte
qui émanait vraiment d'une fosse commune
et ça c'est vraiment sonné j'ai regardé
comment at il pu ne pas retenir autant
témoignages qui ont désigné marc bibeau
comme l'un des principaux responsables
du financement au parti libéral mystère
quelques pages plus loin un autre
mystère
les sollicitations a contribué sont
devenus particulièrement pressante de la
part du parti libéral durant les années
2000 sous la gouverne de jean charest et
marc bibeau
pourquoi renaud lachance a t'il rayer le
nom de jean charest aucun argument
aucune explication france charbonneau à
retirer les noms de marc bibeau et de
jean charest dans ce passage du rapport
final tu indiques dans le texte que des
propos sont insidieux et sans preuve
je ne sais pas pourquoi tu t'exprimes
ainsi je suis à la recherche de la
vérité
tout comme toi si je me trompe dans
l'analyse des textes
il relève de ton de moi de me l'indiquer
respectueusement france
voici l'opinion de renaud lachance il
rejette complètement la conclusion qui
résume le chapitre sur le financement
des partis politiques
il écrit je pense toujours que ses
conclusions à la fin d'un chapitre sur
les récits sont inutiles et
volontairement théâtrale dissidence sera
exprimé clairement sur celle ci par le
commissaire la chance après avoir lu
tout le document france charbonneau
tranche elle conserve l'essentiel de
cette version mais elle enlève quand
même quelques passages adouci certains
termes et remplacent des phrases
tranchée par deux plus longues
explications
le 30 ou france charbonneau reçoit la
réponse de renaud lachance à son
courriel
je veut limiter mes échanges avec toi au
strict minimum nécessaire pour livrer un
rapport pertinent et en respect de
l'échéancier cette attitude s'explique
par ton comportement lors de la révision
de mes premiers commentaires sur le mtq
selon nos sources les deux commissaires
c'était aussi déchiré sur les critiques
contre le gouvernement dans le chapitre
qui concerne le ministère des transports
regarde ton propre nom brille avant de
faire la morale aux autres
renault oui monsieur lachance
oui c'est marie maude denis de
l'émission enquête nous avons appelé
renaud lachance
écoutez monsieur lachance on a obtenu
des informations sur ce qui a mené à
votre dissidence dans le chapitre sur le
financement des partis politiques
et j'aimerais réaliser une entrevue avec
vous à ce sujet je peux pour donner
d'entrevue à fait d'accord